welcome gentlemen you both well yeah I
didn't have time to change so um I left
the house yeah you don't love it
looking over at Alton's outfit and just
there's every interview has another
amazing moment right here the clip down
the leg the golden the golden bedazzled
mint but then the shoes I just realized
the man who made the shoes is in the
audience
oh really Fox is one of the greatest
filmmakers in the world he was ever
heard of the wannabe shoe oh yeah no but
well it was a huge shoe and Patrick
invented it and he's made almost eight
shoes and he's a great cobbler also Cox
is one of my favorite word's
you are a proper Elton John fan I am
it's actually from the beginning I've
been obsessed I kind of wish I was Elton
John like that thing like that
but now what I read in an interview when
the whole interview they kept asking you
questions and all you could do was sing
an Elton John song that you couldn't
remember well I there I I have trouble
remembering lyrics just in general I
remember jams I remember the tunes but
do you remember the one would that you
did that goes like it's just you singing
and piano and ha ha ha yeah Joe please
ah wait this town is all with a one-eyed
anja song take me to the
now take me to the pilot this guy is is
great I mean you've all seen school a
while anyway but I mean this guy's a
real music guy so I love him no limit to
the path now here's the thing Jack back
you just got back from Korea you were in
I was in Korea and China yeah we were
doing Kong zoo bandar we were doing kung
fu panda promotion yeah it does seem all
because it's a cartoon yeah it's not my
voice they got a Chinese person doing
the voice it's not my face it's a
courtship why am i there because they I
think it helps to have a bona fide
Hollywood legend there I give a
high-five to the Chinese actor and I
passed the torch and I don't know why
I'm there fun trip
have you ever children seen Kung Fu
Panda I went to the first one I took my
godson's David Brooklyn Beckham and all
the Beckham boys we went to the sinner
AMA Dom in Hollywood on Sunset Boulevard
and we had a blast and they were in the
back of the car there's Romeo cruise and
Brooklyn and they said uncle Elton I
said yes you rock songs don't you and I
went yeah I said sing us one I said what
you do and it's I just I sang so you
write the Lion King oh that's great so
sing a circle alive then so they it was
fantastic and the film was great
it was just a great experience it's a
such a fun movie
a powder is it up a jaw it's it's a
combination of its really up is it
tightened okay okay okay okay